did you think that writing was going to
be a breeze I did that is until reality
hit growing up I had always been told
that I was a good writer I found it easy
and pretty fun but the deeper I got into
the craft and the more I started paying
attention the less I knew but if that
sounds like you then that's a very good
sign because only amateur writers say
that it's easy as the novelist Thomas
man says a writer is someone for whom
writing is very difficult f for over 20
years and now I lead the writing program
at one of the top universities in South
Korea where I've helped dozens of
researchers get published and countless
students start writing online but let me
tell you it was a grind now I know what
you're thinking how's he been teaching
for 20 years he's only 26 years old
through these years of teaching academic
and professional writing I've discovered
the biggest roadblock holding writers
back they see the elements of writing as
a list of rules rather than a set of
tools so to help you transform your
writing and Unleash Your creativity I'm
sharing 31 writing tools that I wish I
discovered earlier and that'll help you
connect with your readers starting with
number one here's a simple trick that'll
make you writing so much more clear
because the difference between a clear
sentence and a tangled mess that's
overloaded with details all comes down
to this one thing take a look at this
example of a clear sentence from Ryan
holidays Stillness is the key the entire
world changed in the few short hours
between when John F Kennedy went to bed
on October 15th 1962 and when he woke up
the following morning this sentence has
a ton of details in it but it's clear
because the core elements of the
sentence are right up front the first
four words the entire world change tells
you straight away what's happening in
the sentence but watch what happens when
these core elements get buried under
extra words at the start of the sentence
as you'll see in the next example from
the same book anyone who is concentrated
so deeply that a flash of insight or
inspiration suddenly visited them NOS
Stillness here 15 words separate the
subject anyone from the verb knows since
we read from left to right the reader
has to hold the subject in short-term
memory for 15 words before the verb
arrives which is pretty hard work clue
writing is easy for the reader so the
first writing tool is something I call
the locomotive effect when you've got a
sentence with a ton of details put the
subject in the verb right up front that
core Clause the subject in the verb acts
like an and the rest of the details that
follow hitch onto it like train cars and
that way readers will choo choo choose
you as their favorite writer which
brings us to number two if you mean to
make a mistake is it really a mistake
amateur writers are really concerned
with the Notions of right and wrong so
they stick to Safe language and they're
afraid to break the rules of writing but
here's the truth great writers don't
just follow the rules they bend them to
create moments of strangeness take for
example the famous last lines from
Cormac McCarthy's Sury now to give you
context I'm going to read the full
paragraph this occurs right at the end
of the book but watch what happens in
the very last sentence somewhere in the
gray wood by the river is the Huntsman
and in the Brewing corn and in the
castellated Press of cities his work
lies all Wares and his hounds Tire not I
have seen them in a dream slous and wild
and their eyes crazed with ravening for
souls in this world World fly them fly
them isn't that strange like we don't
fly people we fly airplanes we fly
helicopters but you can't fly people you
can flee from people and that's the
literal meaning of this sentence but
McCarthy went with fly here why now
amateurs might consider this to be a
mistake but expert writers can see very
clearly what he's up to here and what
he's up to is the same thing that the
poet and Thomas was doing in that famous
line Do Not Go Gentle into that good
night rage rage against the dying of the
light now here instead of using gently
Thomas goes with gentle Go Gentle which
is technically a mistake this use of
deliberate grammatical mistake is the
second writing tool analogy and expert
writers use it to wrench readers awake
and make moments strange which brings us
to a pretty common tip that you've
probably heard heard before right at a
fifth grade reading level we see it all
over the place especially online for
example here's gwind don't say
stochastic if you can just say random
don't say basy and prior if you can just
say assumption now if you think that
language is just about transmitting
information then gerer would be right
but of course language is not just about
information language is also social and
your choice of words is not only about
the content it's so about your
relationship to the information and to
the reader if you always write at a
fifth grade level then what are you
saying about how you think about your
readers Richard hanania hanania or is it
hanania I don't know how to say his name
makes this point perfectly when you
talks about the difference between
saying I have a prior that the
presidential election will be closed and
I have an assumption that the
presidential election will be close they
look similar but prior comes from the
world of basy and reasoning so if you
say I have a prior then you're
delivering the same information as
assumption but you're also signaling
your membership in a community that
values statistics and Analysis and the
same goes for stochastic versus random
both mean unpredictable but stochastic
is a precise term used in statistics
that shows that you're framing the idea
from that specific perspective always
keeping it simple treats language like
it's just a vehicle for information but
language is so much more than that it's
social so for the third writing tool you
can forget the rule about writing at a
fifth grade level of course you don't
just want to choose puffy words just for
the sake of it cuz they make you sound
like an ass but don't be shy about using
those ingroup code words that carry
special meaning for your readers
speaking of simple what kind of a writer
are you are you a Henning way a fuler or
are you more of a mark [__] Manson
the writing styles of these American
Authors could not have been more
different fauler once critiqued
Hemingway for never daring to use a word
that might send the reader to a
dictionary and Hemingway shot back poor
old fauler does he really think that big
emotions come from big words I know them
all right but there are older simpler
and better words and those are the ones
that I use many people think that
Hemingway won this exchange and his
spare clean writing style is still
really popular in American letters but
Faulkner's point is just as important by
sticking to simple language we risk
underestimating our audience and dulling
down our own Creative Edge plain
language is great for connecting with
readers but sometimes the right word can
really make an idea pop even if it sends
someone to the dictionary so writing
tool number four is a two-parter first
don't be afraid of those $10 words or
with inflation maybe they're more like
$50 words I've been sent to the
dictionary plenty of times by cormack
McCarthy and James Joyce and David
Foster Wallace and I've never regretted
the journey now the second part is don't
be afraid of those cheap words either
look at Mark Manson's best-selling book
The subtle art of not giving a [__] you
won't find language like that in the
works of Hemingway or fauler but that
book became a bestseller because it used
language that resonated and popped in
the minds of their readers there are no
Universal rules for writing because
there are no Universal readers writers
do not have General audiences they have
specific readers and when you know who
those readers are you can use their
language to Signal your in-group status
with them moving on from vocabulary
let's look at a technique for building
tension by looking at examples from it
in poetry and of course Monty Python
look at out the opening lines from TS
Elliott's famous poem The Love Song for
Jay Alfred proofrock creates this
tension let us go then you and I when
the evening is spread out against the
sky like a patient etherized upon a
table now those first two lines are
classic enough they invite the reader
into this romantic evening stroll but
that mood is totally Shattered by that
third line a patient etherized upon a
table what are these two images doing
together and now see the same technique
at work in this classic scene from Monty
pythons The Life of Brian always look on
the bright side of
[Music]
life that contrast between the cheerful
song and their their morbid death
sentence just like the contrast we saw
in the TS Elliot poem joins two writing
tools together the first one is
jposition which just means placing two
things side by side to highlight their
similarities and differences but the
second writing tool that's combined in
these scenes is irony when the literal
meaning of something splits apart from
its meaning in context so if you join
them together what you get is ironic
jposition when you place two objects
side by side so that each one changes
how you see the other and that's the
fifth writing tool for the sixth one
some saying sound so smooth that they
stay stuck in our skulls forever th
thing sound so smooth that they how now
brown cow how now brown cow take for
example the most famous lion from The
Great Gatsby so we beat on boats against
the current born back ceaselessly into
the past what's the secret sauce here
well stick around to see how to use
Simple sounds to shape super strong
sentences super strong sentences if
you've ever heard expressions like
curiosity killed the cat don't throw the
baby out with the bath water and it
takes two to tango then you've already
experienced a writing tool that makes
any phrase memorable even if the meaning
is total nonsense as Mark forsen points
out we naturally love words that start
with the same letter they roll off the
tongue but it's not just that they sound
good this writing tool actually makes
these phrases more persuasive even if
their meaning is total nonsense I mean
curiosity did not kill a cat nobody has
ever thrown a baby out with bathat and
sure it takes two to tango but it takes
two to waltz as well but those SS still
hang around as true and the line from
The Great Gatsby is so memorable because
they sound true and that's the power of
the sixth writing tool alliteration
speaking of The Great Gatsby let's take
another look at that famous message
Gatsby believed in the green light the
orgastic future that yearby year recedes
before us it eluded us then but that's
no matter tomorrow we will run faster
stretch out our arms farther that green
light what's it doing there what does it
mean to believe in a green light in this
passage the green light isn't just the
light at the end of Daisy's do it
becomes a powerful symbol for the
American dream and the way that passage
transitions from a tangible image to an
abstract idea is an example of the
seventh writing tool the ladder of
abstraction at the bottom of the ladder
you find concrete images things that you
can touch see and smell something you
can picture in your mind or stub your
toe on climb if few runs up the ladder
and now you're dealing with abstract
Concepts like Freedom greatness and the
American dream the trick is to balance
these levels sometimes writers get too
caught up on the top layers and their
writing feels disconnected from reality
like it's up there in the clouds other
writers spend all their time down near
the bottom and their work starts to feel
mundane or like journalism it feels like
it doesn't carry any Transcendent
meaning so as you write try to balance
out your ideas by moving up and down the
ladder of abstraction which is our
seventh writing tool now for our eighth
writing tool it's more common in music
but you can use it to write pithy
memorable lines that hang in your reader
mind remember when Jay-Z said I'm not a
businessman I'm a businessman or what
about when the Beatles saying I do all
the pleasing with you it's so hard to
reason with you why do you make me so
blue what were they saying about here
last night I said these words to my girl
I know you never even try girl come on
come on please please me whoo yeah like
I please you but it's not just in music
even Carl Young used this writing tool
when he said the healthy man does not
torture others
generally it is the tortured who turn
into torturers the thing that makes
these lines so catchy and Powerful is
all thanks to a writing technique that
uses a single word in various parts of
speech a technique called poly pooten
polypen popotan I don't know how to say
it it's Greek and it means many cases by
repeating the word in different
structural locations it makes the reader
do a double take and it leaves your
words hanging in the air but but if
you're trying to make a line sound
powerful and deep the best way is not to
be original it's to take what's ordinary
and turn it upside down one master of
this writing tool was Oscar wild who was
famous for these witty onliners that we
still quote today fashion is what one
wears oneself what is unfashionable is
what other people wear journalism is
unreadable and literature is not read
the formula of these lines is pretty
straightforward X is y and not X is not
y so you start with a familiar idea and
then you flip it in an unexpected way
and that sudden contrast is what makes
these statements so striking side note
many people hate the semicolon because
they don't know how to use it and in
many cases you'd be better off nonusing
it but this rhetorical device is the
perfect place to use a semicolon that's
because the negative and the positive
side of a statement don't belong in
separate sentences they belong together
in the same sentence like two sides of
the same coin but you can't just join
two sentences with a comma so instead
you can use a
semicolon this technique is called
antithesis if you want to assert
something forcefully try inverting it
the reason this works is because it
covers both sides of what's true and
what's not true now Charles Darwin notes
that writing is unnatural man has an
instinctive tendency he says to speak as
we see in the babble of our young
children whereas a child has no
instinctive tendency to bake Brew or
write speaking As Natural it occurs
spontaneously with enough input and it's
the medium of social life but writing is
kind of antisocial we do it alone in a
room and for that reason we forget one
of the most important features of
writing it's the thing that author David
Foster Wallace said is the most
important feature of good writing and
it's also the thing that's at the of
Paul Miller's philosophy on writing so
what is that thing well here's what I
tell my undergrad students now of course
this is for an academic context but you
can apply what follows to any writing
context so I tell them imagine a room
with a table of other researchers in
your field they've been sitting there
for a while working on a problem and
it's hard they can't quite figure it out
so they've been devoting a lot of time
and attention to it and it's forcing
them to make certain compromises and to
try new approaches it's a big problem
too so nobody at the table can solve it
on their own this researcher did one
part of the problem this other
researcher did an experiment to
replicate his results and another
researcher is dismantling an assumption
from a previous era Etc now while
they're busy working on this problem you
walk into the room and you want to get a
seat at that table you want them to
accept you so that you can start
contributing to the problem and be a
well-respected member of the field so
what would be a bad way of getting a
seat at that table well if you really
wanted to waste their time then what you
could do is just disregard all the work
that they've done up until that point
don't even talk about it just present
your own ideas independently in a vacuum
in all their Glory or if you really
wanted to piss everyone off what you
could do is just kind of elbow your way
into the table disregard the researchers
and all the work that they've done say
they're all wrong without any
self-awareness or any qualifying remarks
about how they might be right in certain
respects or what the limits of your own
research are now of course you wouldn't
want to adopt their speech patterns you
can just follow the advice of the
writing mavens online who tell you to
avoid jargon and totally disregard The
Insider lingo that these researchers use
in their own little social group that
would be a Surefire way to get yourself
excluded from the group and at that
point it won't even matter how good your
ideas are your social behavior in that
exchange would all but guarantee that
your ideas will be rejected on their
face but what if to the contrary you
actually wanted these people to like you
and accept your ideas well in that case
just do the opposite take an interest in
the work that has come before you show
difference to the big kahunas in the
field reproduce the speech patterns they
use to demonstrate to them your ingroup
status and be polite in laying out your
points of disagreement Pres present
yourself as a helping hand not an
adversary all of this is to say that
writing is communication it's a social
activity and although your readers might
not be a research Community the social
dynamics are exactly the same as Paul
Millard says writing is about entering a
conversation we're always using language
for some purpose and the same thing is
true about writing now if you're writing
valuably then you are contributing
something to an ongoing problem if
you're writing just for yourself then
you're not really writing you're just
journaling so write in the same way that
you would talk with uninterest and
concern for your reader for the 11th
writing tool we're going to tap into a
bit of reader psychology and when you
understand how readers process your
writing at a cognitive level then you
can shape your writing to create certain
effects take a look at this line from
araymond Chandler's story she smells the
way the Taj Mahal looks By Moonlight she
smells the way the Taj Mahal looks what
is it about the way that this image hits
you and why is it so much more powerful
than saying something like she smelled
like pachuli or how about that famous
scene from Apocalypse Now I love the
smell of night palom in the
morning smell you know that gasoline
smell the whole
hell smells like
Victory what makes these lines so vivid
and so memorable well you know how you
might be walking down the street and you
catch a whiff of something and it just
brings you back to this vivid memory
from a long time ago smell has such a
strong relationship to memory because
the part of the brain that processes
smells connects directly to our memory
and emotion centers one of language's
most powerful tools is the ability to
mix up the senses we can use familiar
images to describe an unfamiliar smell
or a familiar smell to describe an
abstract idea we do this all the time a
cold stare a grally voice the Sweet
Taste of Victory these are all examples
of synesthesia using one sense to
describe another and they let us feel a
voice see a sound or even smell an
emotion as a matter of fact at a
fundamental level we don't actually
experience anything through single sense
perception is the experience of
something through all senses in the
really interesting book The spell of the
sensuous which I totally recommend to
all writers the author David Abraham
writes when I perceive the wind surging
through the branches of an aspen tree
I'm unable at first to distinguish the
sight of Those Trembling leaves from
their delicate Whispering my muscles too
feel the torion as those branches Bend
ever so slightly in The Surge and this
imbus the encounter with a a certain
tactile tension the encounter is
influenced as well by the fresh smell of
the Autumn Wind and even by the taste of
the Apple that still lingers on my
tongue so although contemporary
Neuroscience tells us that synesthesia
is a kind of defa or something you
experience as psychedelic effect what
Abrams is saying is that it's actually
the fundamental experience so experiment
with synesthesia start mixing up the
senses because the effect is that it's
not exactly magic realism as see in the
Raymond Chandler passage there's
something very Vivid about it so if
you're writing about an idea try to
ground it into something more concrete
by blending it with one or more of the
senses now do you remember that famous
scene from The Wizard of Oz where the
Wicked Witch of the West yells fly my
pretties
fly really that's odd because she never
actually said that take special care of
those Ruby sippers I want those most of
all now die f
[Music]
what is it that makes so many people
misremember this iconic line well here's
the same writing tool used in another
famous scene that you definitely
remember I admire your luck Mr
Bond James Bond these lines are so
iconic all thanks to a writing tool
called diacon
a technique where a word or phrase is
repeated after a brief Interruption that
repetition creates a kind of verbal
sandwich that etches the line into your
memory and there are a few variations of
it now there's the vocative diapy
vocative just means you address somebody
drill baby
drill what motorcycle is this it's a
chopper baby whose Chopper is this Zed's
who Zed Zed's Dead baby dead dead
there's elaboration
diabe captain my captain there's
extended diabe oh Romeo
Romeo with for
Romeo
last diaby diapy all the best onliners
use diapy for lucky number 13 if you've
ever read John steinbach's The Grapes of
Wrath then you definitely remember this
Unforgettable speech I'll be everywhere
wherever you can
look wherever there's a fight so hungry
people can eat I'll be
there wherever there's a cop beating up
a guy I'll be
there I'll be in the way guys yell when
they're
mad I'll be in the way kids laugh when
they're hungry and they know supper's
ready
and when the people are eating the stuff
they raise
and living in the houses they
build I'll be there too see how they
keep on returning to the core message
after adding long sets of details that's
epistrophe a technique where you repeat
the same word or phrase at the end of
successive Clauses or sentences like the
course of a song epistrophe helps your
readers stay focused on your core
message as you continue to add new
details to it they [__] you up your mom
and your dad they may not mean to but
they do that famous line from the poet
Philip Larin uses a little grammar trick
that you can use to launch your reader
into the rest of your story it's the
same writing tool that we see at the
start of Ernest Hemingway's Old Man and
the Sea he was an old man who fished
alone in a skiff in the Gulf Stream and
he had gone 84 days without taking a
fish in fact this writing tool is so
powerful that we even find it in the
classic opening to all scary stories it
was a dark and stormy night what these
lines have in common is that the first
word is an ambiguous pronoun now
normally pronouns link backwards to a
noun that has already been mentioned but
in these examples the pronoun links for
wordss to a noun that has not yet been
introduced readers cannot tolerate that
ambiguity it opens up a loop that they
want to close who [__] us up who is the
old man these questions spark curiosity
and they pull the reader into to the
rest of your story this clever writing
tool is known as prolapsus by starting
with an ambiguous pronoun you motivate
your readers and launch them straight
into the heart of your story when David
Foster Wallace writes about his
experience aboard a cruise ship he
doesn't just describe it he drowns you
in the details and that flood of details
is exactly why his essay a supposedly
fun thing I'll never do again became a
non-fiction classic here are just a few
lines from the famous opening of that
essay I have now seen sucr beaches and a
water of very bright blue I have seen an
all red leisure suit with flared lapels
I have smelled suntan lotion spread over
2100 lbs of hot flesh I have been
addressed as bon in three different
nations I have seen 500 upscale
Americans danced the Electric Slide I
have seen sunsets that looked computer
enhanced I have very briefly joined a
conga line I have seen a lot of very big
white ships I have seen schools of
little fish with fins that glow I have
seen and smelled all 145 cats inside the
earnest Hemingway residence in Key West
Florida I now know the difference
between Street Bingo and pizo I have
seen fluorescent luggage and FL ENT
sunglasses and fluorescent pain snays
and over 20 different makes of rubber
thong I have heard steel drums and eaten
con fritters and watched a woman in
silver lame projectile vomit inside a
glass elevator I have pointed
rhythmically at the ceiling to the two4
beat of the same disco music I hated
pointing at the ceiling to in
1977 this sequence of images is
disjointed and sometimes surprising but
they all come together to form a
tapestry or a mosaic that establishes a
rich context and that was only the
opening paragraph but after two pages of
these images you really get the feeling
that you're standing there on the deck
with the author this flood of sensory
details is an example of a writing tool
called conju a rhetorical strategy that
piles up adjectives nouns and images to
create an immersive almost overwhelming
experience now this next writing tool
was passed down to me from my thesis
adviser in University it's something he
discovered whenever he was working on
his PhD dissertation his dissertation
Supervisor was Walter Ben Michaels an
academic literary critic who's very well
known for being an outstanding writer
and stylist now you don't even have to
be interested in American lit to enjoy
his writing it's just so clear his
arguments are rock solid and he just
knows how to make his ideas pop off the
page so you can imagine that if this was
your supervisor you might feel a little
timid about the quality of your own
writing especially among academics who
basically write Arguments for a living
it's really important to not only have
important new ideas but to also be able
to write about them in a clear style and
that's when my thesis adviser developed
this writing tip steel style stealing
style is a way of bringing a writer's
voice into your own to steal style you
find a writer who you admire analyze
their sentences and sections and try to
slot your own ideas into those
structures now he told me that when he
started doing this he felt a little bit
nervous about bringing one of his
chapters to his adviser for feedback but
lo and behold his adviser was praising
him as a good writer and he said that he
sat there kind of thinking to himself
like oh my God you don't even realize it
these are your sentences now of course
we're talking about style here not ideas
ideas are under copyright but style is
open source it's yours for the taking so
if you want to steal style here's a
quick exercise ask a few of your writer
friends which authors they admire and
why pick a couple of Articles or stories
from those writers and find a phrase or
a passage that stands out to you read it
two or three times and this part's
important close the book and try to
write out that section that you just
read start with individual sentences but
try to work your way up to paragraphs
and maybe even sections the more you do
this the more their writing style will
seep into your own voice for writing
tool number 17 listen to what Kendrick
Lamar told Rick ruin about how he writes
do you make notes definitely all the
time I have to make notes because a lot
of my inspiration come from meeting
people or going outside of the country
or going around the corner to my old
neighborhood talking to a 5-year-old
little boy and I have to remember these
things you know I have to uh write them
down and then five or 3 months later I
have to find that same emotion that I
felt when I was inspired by it so I had
to dig all the way deep and see what
were the things that triggered the idea
of does it always come back it comes
back it comes back it comes cuz I have
key little words that make me uh realize
the exact motion and what Drew the
inspiration and he's not alone Robert
Green does the same thing and it's
exactly the same technique that he
taught his prote Ryan holiday now
there's nothing systematic about this
these little scraps of paper just pile
up you don't know where it's leading you
when you're writing it down and you
might never use it again some of these
notes just become orphans but others
begin to Cluster and aggregate around
larger ideas and as a writer you'll
start to notice the through lines that
link them together into these
constellations and that's how these
little scraps of paper become ideas of
your own only it's much easier for us
today because we don't have to haul
around these shoe boxes full of notes
personally I love to use the app
obsidian it's free open- source and it
doesn't store your files on a server
meaning you never have to worry about
data loss or privacy but more
importantly is the architecture of the
app unlike notion which is organized
hierarchically with these nesting Pages
obsidian is designed to be horizontal
which means that at any moment any note
can be linked to any other note so
anytime you're creating a new note you
can just Chuck it into the Vault and
forget about it until one day weeks or
even years down the road when something
new occurs to you and you want to pull
it up it's the perfect app for this
messy chaotic note-taking system and
it's what I recommend for you to use for
this writing tool which I call
collecting scraps now for writing tools
18 and 19 take a look at this passage
because it's got a problem in it one day
as the watching of an informative and
entertaining YouTube video was taking
place on the part of the clever writer
the Creator's subtle requests to like
share and subscribe occurred causing the
writer Amusement that passage was hard
to read it's a lot easier to read it if
it's written like this one day a clever
writer was watching a YouTube video that
was informative and entertaining when
the Creator subtly requested her to like
share and subscribe which amus her what
makes that one better than the first one
in these passages there are two writing
tools at work first ask yourself what's
this story about obviously the story has
two main characters it a clever writer
that's you and the video creator in the
first case these characters are tucked
away into these subordinate positions
but in the second passage they're placed
more prominently in the hierarchy of the
sentence so the first writing tool at
work here is to make the main characters
of your story the subjects of verbs now
second ask yourself what's going on here
what's happening in this story and what
you're going to find is that the main
actions are watching requesting and
amusing so in the first case these
actions are represented in nouns in the
second case these actions are seated in
the verb which is the heart of the
sentence so the second writing tool is
Place specific actions in verbs not
nouns for writing tool number 20 do you
remember that great scene in No Country
for Old Men when luel and Moss finds the
Briefcase full of money cybar you've got
to read the book now yeah yeah everyone
says the book is better but seriously
what's really interesting about the book
No Country for Old Men is that corack
McCarthy first wrote it as a screenplay
it was rejected so he adapted it into a
novel which the Cohen Brothers then
picked up and adapted into a movie but
because the novel was first a screenplay
it's incredibly spare So reading the
novel is like admiring a great engine
it's simple and Compact and elegant in
its structure and Design so I highly
recommend it and speaking of engines the
reason that that's scene with the
briefcase is so incredible is that it
functions as the engine of the story
that single moment when luell and
discovers the money is the start of the
tragedy the first domino in the line it
immediately raises a series of questions
is he going to take the money who's the
money belong to is he going to get away
with it questions that demand answers
and hook you in for the rest of the
story that one moment is the engine of
the entire story it fires up the
narrative and keeps you eager to find
out how the rest of the story unfolds so
when you're writing your own story you
should hopefully be able to point to
that one moment in the opening that
serves as the engine of your story the
one that drives forward the rest of your
story as it drags your reader behind it
now for a harsh truth but one that will
hopefully help you right in a way that
your readers will find engaging and
valuable and that's the key word here
value so much writing advice focuses on
the formal elements of writing it says
that writing should be clear organized
and persuasive but guess what if your
writing is clear and useless it's
useless if your writing is organized and
useless it's useless if your writing is
persuasive and useless it's useless
readers do not care about Clarity
organization or persuasion those
elements are just the vehicles for
delivery But ultimately your writing
needs to do one thing deliver value so
what is value it sounds like an abstract
thing but in fact it's very clear and
precise readers perceive writing as
valuable when it solves a problem that
they care about now I don't mean to
sound too utilitarian about that of
course we do all kinds of things in our
writing there's self-expression and
writing about ideas and opinions but the
fact is that if those things aren't
motivated towards solving a problem that
readers care about then nobody's going
to read it so the writing tool here
begins with a mistake don't write about
topics nobody cares about topics if you
start off with in this piece I will
explore the topic of readers have
already left the building Instead at the
top of your page you should be able to
fill out a problem statement like this
I am writing about topic because I want
to find out about question in order to
help my reader gain a benefit or avoid a
consequence with these kinds of problem
statements topics are motivated to
answering a question and the answer to
that question will either help the
reader gain a benefit or avoid a
consequence now of course you don't need
to give the reader that problem
statement it doesn't need to be at the
top of your published work but fill at
this kind of a problem statement will
really help you keep everything on track
that way you'll be able to delete
anything that doesn't directly
correspond to that problem statement
reading tool 22 garbage collectors in
New York City have a special term for
the maggots that they find in the trash
disco rice and that is about as good a
metaphor as you can ever hope to find
but even if you can't write a metaphor
this good do your best to avoid cliché
they drained the life out of your
writing George Orwell warns us that
relying on cliches is a shortcut a
substitute for Creative thought in his
book politics and the English language
Orwell argues that bad writing is the
result of bad thinking and that bad
writing has a corrosive effect on
civilization and in that passage he
singles out cliches which he calls dying
metaphors dying metaphors have lost all
evocative power and are merely used
because they save people the trouble of
inventing phrases for themselves now if
Orwell is right then writers have a
civic duty to keep our language vigorous
and Alive actively responding to and
reflecting the culture using dying
metaphors or cliches is just empty talk
it doesn't mean anything but the role of
the writer has always been to detect the
signs of cultural change saying what
people think before they even even
realize it and offering up these images
to the culture so writing tool 22 is
Beware of the cliche speaking of Orwell
he also said that good writing should be
like a window pane so clear that readers
can see the world and not the writer in
other words the best writing doesn't
draw attention to itself it simply lets
the story shine through this idea is
especially important when dealing with
heavy subjects here are two approaches
to a heavy subject from the filmmaker
Steven Spielberg first in the movie
Schindler's List the [__] of the
Holocaust aren't exaggerated or
sensationalized instead the movie relies
on this quiet restraint which allows the
suffering to speak for itself and the
result is haunting compare that approach
to another movie Saving Private Ryan
where Spielberg takes the opposite
approach the opening sequence throws you
into the chaos of war with brutal detail
every explosion every wound every moment
of Terror is laid bare now both films
are powerful but for different reasons
and I think that the restrained style of
Schindler's List is more engaging for
the imagination it really forces the
audience to imagine the worst and fill
in the gaps on their own similarly in
your writing you don't need to make
everything so explicit you're not trying
to make Saving Private Riot when dealing
with serious subjects step back and let
the weight of the story do the work
understate the serious and overstate the
light let your tone match the weight of
your subject and your writing will carry
that much more impact number 24 is all
about names think about all the
unforgettable characters from literature
there's Vladimir Nabokov with Humber
Humber David Foster Wallace with Rick
vigorous or Howen Kenza but the real
king of characters with interesting
names is Thomas Pinchin and here are the
top 10 names of Thomas Pinchin
characters Tyrone sloth Rob from
gravity's rainbow Mike fallopian from
the crying of lot 49 meatball Mulligan
from entropy from a slow learner
Reverend Wix Cheroke from Mason Dixon
Pig Bodine from both V and gravity's
rainbow slab from V Scarsdale vibe from
against the day Benny profane and
mclinic sphere from V and coming into at
number one is Sano smile Ax from
inherent Vice who was played by bonio
Del Toro in the film adaptation now
inter names aren't only for people
they're also places I grew up not far
from a village called St Louis deah yes
with the exclamation points and I always
thought that that town was a story
waiting to be told and that's writing
tool number 24 collect interesting names
and let them invite you to write their
story you don't have to have the
character or the place first you can
start with an interesting name write it
down and then see what that name is
inviting you to write about writing tool
25 is something I call the Bilbo moment
now think about how The Hobbit begins
Gandalf doesn't just throw Bilbo into
this chaotic Adventure right away first
he secures a commitment from Bilbo he
gives him a visit and gives him enough
time to feel somewhat comfortable before
the real Journey Begins now as writers
we should be a little bit like Gandalf
and do the same thing for our readers
before you dive into your argument or
your big idea you've got to build trust
that means starting with example that
are clear simple and easy to grasp
something that your reader can
confidently nod along to now you'll find
this technique in most popular
non-fiction but just for an example I've
got a copy of Sam Harris's waking up and
a more recent title from natalis crypto
confidential so take a look at how these
stories open now with Sam Harris's
waking up it's an argument about how we
can have spirituality without religion
and it's kind of a complex argument that
involves Neuroscience religion ethics
and at times can be a little bit
demanding but the book starts off with a
vivid story about how Sam Harris went on
an overnight camping trip as a teenager
and later taking a trip to Nepal that
would completely transform his view
about our place in the cosmos now that
simple story opens up the conceptual
field in which his argument is going to
unfold you also see this at the start of
nat Elias's book crypto confidential in
which he tells a nerve-wracking story
about finding out that he was a few
months away from becoming a father now
this of course has nothing to do with
cryptocurrency but it sets a context a
frame in which the rest of the story and
its Stakes will be interpreted and
that's what I call the Bilbo effect a
straightforward concrete story that lays
the foundation for everything that
follows as time goes on Gandalf brings
Bilbo into a world of dwarves quests and
dragons and likewise in non-fiction you
can start introducing more abstract
ideas like spirituality or
cryptocurrency but only once the reader
is on board structure your examples from
simple to complex from literal to
metaphorical lay the groundwork with
clear accessible evidence and then build
on it stretching your argument with
nuance and depth be Gandalf guide your
reader from familiar territory into the
more intricate transformative terrain of
your world begin with your bilbo moment
for writing tool number 26 the legend
musician Frank Zappa nailed it when he
complained that most guitar solos are
played the same way every night do you
consider yourself a great guitarist well
I'm specialized what I do on the guitar
has uh very little to do with what other
people do on the
guitar most of the other guitar solos
that you hear performed on stage have
been practiced over and over and over
again they go out there and they play
the same one every night and it's really
just spotless my theory is this I have a
basic mechanical knowledge of the
operation of the instrument and I got an
imagination and when the time comes up
in the song to play a solo it's me
against the laws of nature I don't know
what I'm going to play I don't know what
I'm going to do I know roughly how long
I have to do it and it's a game where
you have a piece of time and you get to
decorate it that's the spirit you need
when you write when you sit down to
create don't overthink every word until
it's perfectly rehearsed instead set a
fixed piece of time say 20 minutes take
a deep deep breath and let it rip treat
that timed interval like a live solo be
unpredictable and raw and full of that
thrill of
improvisation you have basic knowledge
of the instrument which is grammar and
vocabulary you've got an imagination and
you've got taste so when the time comes
to write rip a solo and leave the
results to Nature now of course this is
not going to be perfect if you listen to
Frank Zappa's solos they weren't perfect
but the best stuff never is for wrting
Tool number 27 think about that classic
rule from Comedy the rule of three where
you set up a pattern with two beats and
then you hit your punchline with a Twist
in non-fiction writing authors sometimes
develop an idea using the wrong strategy
that's the ABA structure presenting an
example then a contrast and then
circling back to the original example
but with this structure the reader never
gets a chance to fully grasp the core
idea before it's been muddied by the
contradiction so instead start by
presenting two similar examples that
clearly Hammer home your key Point
that's AA and then only after your
reader has soaked in that idea do you
introduce a contrasting example which is
your B that contrasting example
challenges or deepens the original Point
laid out in the two A's the steady build
of AA creat it's a solid foundation
which makes that final twist in the B
all the more surprising and impactful
for writing tool 28 imagine you were
writing about a watch if you write
something like this is the minute hand
this is the second hand this is the
clock face that's called descriptive
writing and it's not really telling the
reader anything useful it's just
information valuable writing goes
further it doesn't just repeat facts it
finds patterns unpacked underpinnings
and uses all this information to solve
problems that readers actually care
about so with the watch instead of just
naming its parts you could explain how
the gears turn What mechanisms allow the
hands to move in sync and how does
everything align with our experience of
time that's called analytical writing it
shows the bigger picture it's not
information but analysis that makes your
writing not only interesting but
valuable for writing duel 29 consider
this sentence there was worry that there
would be extra homework assigned who's
doing the worrying who's doing the
assigning to whom was the homework
assigned this sentence has been bled dry
by zombie nouns that's when action is
represented not as an active verb but as
a lifeless noun so instead of using
zombie nouns you can punch up your Pros
by putting real characters in the
driver's seats and actions in verbs the
students worried that the teacher would
assign them extra homework when you
replace vague static phrases with active
verbs and concrete subjects it brings
your writing to life your sentences are
more than information the way you
arrange that information in the sentence
gives the reader a lot of information
about how they should interpret your
sentence so beware zombie nouns and
instead use active verbs that animate
the story into something that the reader
can picture because the best writing is
visual it creates a movie in your mind's
eye writing tool number 30 home stretch
here are two sentences and just a
warning the first one kind of sucks
since most startup companies pivot their
business models at least once during
their early years firsttime
entrepreneurs who are not certain about
the direction of their Venture should
not commit all their resources to a
single strategy did you notice the way
that sentence begins compare it with
this rewrite first time entrepreneurs
should not commit all their resources to
a single strategy if they are not
certain about the direction of their
Venture because most startup companies
pivot their business models at least
once during their early years long
winded introductory phrases force your
reader to hold on to details in their
short-term memory while waiting for the
main point which can really bog down
their comprehension so if you find your
sentence starting with a long
introductory clause consider moving it
to the end or splitting it up into a
separate sentence this way your reader
gets to the heart of your message faster
and with less cognitive load and for
writing tool number 31 consider this
clunky example we must cultivate if we
are to inspire Future Leaders a deep
understanding of community engagement
readers want to get straight to the
action past the verb and onto its object
but notice how that interrupting Clause
turns this sentence into a mental
obstacle course as the reader moves
through this sentence in time that
interrupting Clause makes it hard to see
that cultivate is directly tied to a
deep understanding of community
engagement so instead try moving the
interrupting element to either the
beginning or the end depending on what
comes next so if the following sentence
begin with the word communities then you
would want that interrupting element to
be at the end of the sentence such as if
we are to inspire Future Leaders we must
cultivate a deep understanding of
community engagement these communities
May on the other hand if the next
sentence Begins by mentioning leaders
then you could arrange the sentence as
follows we must cultivate a deep
understanding of community engagement if
we are to inspire Future Leaders these
leaders May readers read most easily
when they get through the core of your
sentence so keep the verb closely
connected to its objects by the way if
you got this far then well done because
I've got to tell you as I was
researching for this video I was like
man I want to try like 15 of these
writing tools in my next piece but the
problem with that is that it's going to
cause overwhelm confusion and just more
problems when you should really focus on
just one of these so instead of trying
15 of these in your next piece watch
this video next because it's going to
give you a simple principle that you can
follow to make your writing more clearer
so be sure to go check it out
[Music]